hey everyone welcome back to game Sports
coverage of e3 2019 I'm Lisa James
joined by Mike Mahadi
and joining us from Respawn
Entertainment is drew McCoy program
project lead on apex legends thank you
for joining us
no worries I'm happy to be here yeah so
at EA play at the weekend you talked a
little bit more about season 2 yep let's
let's dive into that what was the fan
reaction like it's been really good so
far I mean I'm always reading Twitter
and reddit in the forums and everything
and I think for most part people are
excited you know we've got a lot of
stuff coming at once we're trying to
package up as much as we can to try and
give the game like on one day a bunch of
new things people to experience unlock
and play with so let's go what's the top
down view of what players can expect
with season 2 yes so with season 2
launching we have a new character a new
weapon we got ranked mode coming we've
got some balance changes a new battle
paths it's a lot of stuff at once
alright let's kick off with the battle
path then so the first part of us came
out and you know a lot of people
underwhelmed underwhelmed yeah
self-aware and I mean it was you know
there was a grind but now what what have
you learned from that battle path that
you're taking into the new one yeah so a
lot of the changes for the season to
battle paths are based off of that
feedback from our community so the
biggest change is probably the fact that
it's challenge based now so you get
daily and weekly challenges and they
stack so if you don't play for weeks or
months during the season come back
you'll have a whole grip of challenges
for you to true through and that
ultimately makes levelling up a lot
faster people are having a difficult
time getting to level hundred on the
season one battle pass we really want it
to be a good wave players to explore the
only new content and have fun
progression and it just didn't work out
as we'd hoped in season one so along
with that we've got we've gotten rid of
some of the lower value items that
people will complain about so a lot of
that track is it going yeah stat
trackers and badges ten of those things
that were just kind of filler for people
we're replacing with all new types of
content they've been in the game before
we're not talking about them yet but
they're pretty cool some of them haven't
even been in other games okay so stay
tuned for more in
so on that we have three more legendary
skins yep
to the battle pass so there's a one for
octane one for caustic one two for the
301 and two for the ER one for the stiff
fighter and Oh Hugh Jass when the
community was more crafting metals so by
the end of season or the battle pass
you'll have enough happening metals to
craft your own legendary of choosing so
you talk a little bit about buffs and
nerfs to some weapons you mentioned them
well it was alluded to the Mosin do the
beak am i because I'm one of those
people who will ping it in every single
game I just get that little gleeful
laugh oh yeah am I still is it gonna be
changed enough that my joke is still
good you're still work don't worry
and at some point it'll just become a
knowing joke of like aha yeah I remember
when perhaps how do you even approach I
mean cuz that the gun is essentially a
big mean for your community how do you
even approach tackling changing it so we
actually really like it
the fun thing from a design perspective
about a battle royale is not every a gun
needs to be balanced for maximum
efficiency but got crap your guns and
you got some really good guns that's
part of the fun of Battle Royale so
we've kind of embraced the meme like if
you saw with the most recent patch
there's a new switch out animation if
you have the Mozambique but actually
every weapon to us has a specific use
whether that's early game you know you
get a P 2020 pistol it's got to do what
it's got to do while you're in that
first circle versus late-game
so we're looking at ways to maybe change
up how people think about certain guns
at various stages of the game through
attachments and hop ups and stuff like
that it's funny apex Legends was such a
hard left turn for despite the fact that
it's a first-person shooter for a
respawn it was a hard left turn you know
it's got like some of that respawn DNA
and it's so to speak but not only is it
just a battle royale which is new for
you guys it's also like a game just
service an ongoing thing you've added
DLC to titanfall 2 etc but it's pretty
much a trial by fire for you guys what's
it like I mean like five years ago you
wouldn't have been able to say yeah we
are aware that seas
was overwhelming we're season 2 as a
result of that like what's it like this
stuff this whole new world for you guys
uh you know we're still in the middle of
learning how to really operate our
brains are wired to kind of ship a game
maybe do some DLC but then kind of go
underground and do lots of stuff over
the course of multiple years that
converge on one ship date and we've
gotten really really good at that that's
kind of our superpower but as a team but
now we've got to kind of converge and
ship all the time so we're trying to
figure it we've been trying to figure
out the best way for our team to operate
in this way because for us crunch is not
really acceptable for us or we think for
our players because we've invested
decades into our team like the core of
this team has been making games together
for twenty years so if we crunch our
guys and people burn out and leave now
our games not going to be as good
because we can't just throw extra people
on it like we have a lot of trust and
ownership on everyone on the team to
make really good stuff so we've had to
figure out how do we work on stuff we
want to come out say two years from now
in Apex as well as stuff you want to
come out in a month or a week and that's
just a big logistical and kind of like
pipeline and tools it's a big problem
and I think we're getting better at it
it's also that really tough paradox of
like how much feedback do you take
before you start making it their game
and not your own and how like much do
you want to make of your own before you
just start ignoring players like
obviously like it's a balance you want
to find but what's that challenge like
so before apex we've pretty much made
games that we thought were cool we did a
lot of what you call focus testing we'd
bring in at some random off the street
play the game for a day while we watched
like creepers with cameras and stuff and
just kind of that was good for us to
find out where people get stuck in
things like that we were never asking
for feedback on how to make the game
better
whereas with Apex even during
development we were doing lots of market
research we were doing research on the
game before it was really playable by
players just like on the concept and
it's been a learning experience as well
but at the core of it it's still the
game that we want to make and we think
has a really good place in the in the
market
and that doesn't change just because
everyone's gonna complain about
something doesn't mean we're gonna
change it because often times players
actually save one thing but then we have
data from tens of millions of players
saying something else and that's a hard
pill for our community to swallow
sometimes we stand by it and we will
screw up and we have screwed up and
we'll like you know our bad we'll fix it
but it's it's a balancing act and
sometimes we'll sit around and have
arguments about well you know there's a
thread on reddit saying this versus yeah
but really this mechanic was supposed to
be doing that like an example would be
we recently took out the ability to do
the bunny hop while healing and that's a
really interesting kind of knife to look
at decision-making by because when we
were developing the game we wanted
healing to be a choice you make and so
if you do it doing combat you're you're
putting yourself at a disadvantage or
slow you can't shoot bla bla bla bla bla
all these things so just because players
found an exploit allows you to move
quickly while healing doesn't mean that
was our intention and it actually was
having a negative effect on the flow of
combat from our perspective we might be
wrong on that so far you know players
some players are really upset about it
but so far it's actually been a very
positive change and how do you go about
balancing for you know the top 1% the
pro players the shrouds yeah this is the
regular Joe's like the rest of us so I
think actually one of our strengths has
usually been making a game that feels
like the regular Joe can pick up the
game and have fun and feel effective
while still having enough depth where
you can play the game for tens hundreds
of thousands of hours and that's just
one of those black magic dark arts that
I don't fully understand as where could
we play test the game hours every day
like 1 to 3 hours a day whether it's
stuff that's really far out like a year
to go down the road or if it's stuff
we're trying to release really soon and
it's it's one of those things where it's
just you gotta it's the right people
doing the right work at the right time
and there really isn't like a formula
for it I think there's a world where the
reception to Apex legends was is was
different I mean like the titanfall 2
was such a beloved game title one was as
well so I think people were just like
waiting for titanfall 3 etc and then
again you do this like drastic change
were you surprised with how great the
reception was because I think like for
all intensive purposes it was a great
reception ya know
I'm still not sure how that happens like
it's still surprising and awesome when I
think back to how that played out
because with a traditional box game you
have pre-orders you have trailers to get
views on YouTube and everywhere you see
how many people subscribe to your
Twitter account all these things they
give you an indication that how many
people are gonna show up in that first
week so when we just surprise announce
and launch the game we just kind of like
hold on to something we don't know
what's gonna happen and so we had
estimates that we thought were okay they
were trying to be conservative so we
weren't you know it's putting too much
on marketing and this or that we blew
those estimates away for the first two
months in the first 24 hours and you
just nothing really prepares you for
that and we were still just figuring out
how to live after that so you talk about
adding new content to the game and
obviously the biggest and piece of
content that changes the game
fundamentally is the addition of new
legends that we saw Watson she was
revealed at the weekend how long do you
guys been iterating on her finding her
place within the meta of Apex legends
and what's it been like to see the fan
reaction to her so people have no idea
how long stuff takes to make in games
like just players and the reality is our
legends take us I think the quickest one
has been 14 months most of them about a
year and a half Watson you know we
actually had some streamers come out to
the studio last July and they were
playing Watson back then we've been
paying Watson I think since spring last
year because the character only takes a
week or two to get that really early
prototype in the game and then from
there we iterate and iterate and iterate
and so it really comes down to that play
testing culture we have like one of the
big problems we had after we shipped the
game was how do we divert our time
between testing a patch that needs to go
out next week testing content needs come
out a month and testing content needs to
come out in six months and what was
happening was the content that was
coming out in six or nine twelve months
it wasn't getting play tested enough and
the designers were raising their hands
and saying I don't know if my stuff is
good enough so that's one of those
problems we had to solve we've added
play testing time to our daily schedules
but that's where a lot of those
decisions come into play because we're
playing our game a ton
and Watson specifically she was born out
of a desire from the designers to have
more defensive options in the game
because right now caustics kind of your
only one so she was born out of that
player type that really wants to think
ahead
the defensive kind of try and control a
fight on their terms and then from there
it just grew into the character they all
go to see and play in a month I guess
it's really because you're designing and
developing these characters so far in
advance you can't necessarily predict
how the meta and how people are going to
play those characters you know months
down the line so how do you even
possibly go about designing for that
well we have a really good understanding
of the basic fundamentals of the game
and the characters and kind of the meta
we get surprised sometimes in the live
game but what players do and what they
attach to and how far they push some of
these abilities but for Watson
specifically she's filling a role that
doesn't exist yet and I'm sure we'll
have made some mistakes and so when she
launches want to make some balance
adjustments but because of our play
testing I think she'll launch in a
really good state and additionally we
usually have like we have tons of
characters already in development at
various stages some that'll never ship
some little ship maybe two years from
now if at all and some that are getting
closer and that gives us the opportunity
to kind of look at those early risers
and kind of put more resources behind
them as well as looking at how the live
game is doing and say you know what this
character is probably gonna suit us
better so let's put them further ahead
and put more resources behind them when
it comes to adding law and context to a
character's Watson's of the instrumental
in the creation of the games equation at
the arena is that you know do you have
story beats and they get then assigned
to a character but but like judging by
when they actually come up through
development or those elements kind of
put into the character from the
beginning it depends
so character is usually born from a
mechanical place of defensive character
and then once the abilities are known
then it goes over to concept art and
they kind of figure out where's this
character going to look at it look like
but that's in concert with animators who
need to figure out how this character
gonna emote as well as the writers are
gonna figure out who is
character where'd they come from why do
they fight in the arena so that's a big
hodgepodge back and forth that's a large
part of why the process takes so long
because we're not just trying to give
gay players gameplay we're trying to
give them like something to attach to
emotionally the fact that we have so
much fan art people cause playing our
characters it really shows to me that we
are doing something good in that arena
and players are attaching these
characters and with Watson specifically
being that she is an engineer and she
has these wire lines it's all
electricity based there's a really cool
connection that we could have there of
writing her as the as the one who kind
of figured out how the ring should work
we have a bunch of other stuff that the
world will probably never see like we
have an internal kind of like universe
guide that so as developers at respawn
are working on a piece of content they
can kind of immerse themselves in why
does this thing exist where did it come
from who made it all these things so
that we try and be as consistent as
possible and really create that universe
for players to attach to it's super
interesting I'm fascinated by the idea
like how has respawns like workflow
changed because of Apex legends or like
to adapt to apex legends right it's not
this traditional release model anymore
it's release a game get feedback right
tweak the things in DB tweak plan the
future of the roadmap what has it been
like transitioning into that
specifically from like a workflow
standpoint four or respawned
well it's actually forced us to put a
magnifying glass to some of our
processes that worked fine again we're
trying to converge on one point two and
a half years down the road where there's
a lot of slop that we could soak up but
when you got to do that all the time we
have to find a lot more efficiencies in
our process it's like I was saying
characters taking us a year and a half
that's not gonna be long-term
sustainable we want to be shipping
characters faster than we currently are
so right now we're in a big big process
right now to figure out how can we do
that without crunching our team without
just throwing extra people at the
problem because for us hiring is also a
really slow and somewhat arduous process
we started the team nine years ago with
30 people and now we're only about 120
and it's taking us that long and we've
been hiring constantly
that process we can't just oh wait
here's five hundred resumes hire those
people put them at desks and so it's
really had a profound impact on our our
development processes pipeline tools all
that kind of stuff I can't possibly let
you leave the stage without asking a
couple of questions but I know you won't
building something the answers to but I
have to say you never know number one is
to deal with that big dragon boy what's
the line I was allowed to say a couple
big things are making their way the
Kings came in but I will say I was
following the reddit thread about the
space cows I just keep your eyes peeled
I'll say over the next few weeks okay
and finally I mean so I think I met you
a few years ago when you still on the
titanfall team and obviously respawn is
now working on Star Wars Jedi fallen
order as well as FX legends is there any
hope for people who still are waiting
for that third titanfall game you know I
mean respawn was born out of titanfall
it has a huge amount of identity for the
studio itself and we all love it very
dearly who knows what that comes to in
the future but we definitely care a lot
about titanfall and what it brings to
the game industry thank you so much for
joining us guys make sure if you're
watching at home that you don't go
anywhere
coming up next we're gonna be speaking
with Todd Howard about the future of
fallout 76
[Music]
you